يقول التطبيق الشهير للهواتف الذكية ، tick
tock ، إنه يعلق بعض
ميزاته في روسيا في ضوء
قانون الأخبار الكاذبة في البلاد ، لكن في أوكرانيا ، أصبح
tick tock مزدهرًا ويستخدم أحد
المصورين المنصة
لتحويل صوت صفارات الإنذار إلى فن
[موسيقى]
تستخدم فاليريا شاشانوك علامة Tick-tock
لتوثيق حياتها في مخبأ
وشمال أوكرانيا ، وقد انتشرت مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بها على نطاق واسع
وحصلت على ملايين المشاهدات لأنها
تُظهر للعالم كيف يبدو الأمر
للنجاة من العدوان الوحشي في روسيا
تنضم إلي فاليريا الآن مرحباً فاليريا ، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك على  قادمًا لمشاركة
قصتك أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، أخبرنا كيف حالك
أنت وعائلتك الآن.
المكان الأكثر أمانًا من
ملجأ القنابل ،
لذا نعم ، يجب أن يكون الأمر سرياليًا أن
تستيقظ وتعتقد أنك في وسط
منطقة حرب ، فأنت معرض
للعدوان الروسي في أي
لحظة لا تعرف ما الذي
سيحدث  n لكنك تمكنت من
توثيقها كما رأينا في هذا الفيديو
على الشاشة
في حساب tick tock الخاص بك ، لديك
ربع مليون متابع الآن على وضع علامة
tock ما يقرب من 10 ملايين إعجاب
أي الكثير من الأشخاص حول العالم
انتبه إلى كل ما
تشاركه ، كيف قررت أي جزء من
حياتك يجب أن تضعه في وضع علامة تعرف
أنني مصور فوتوغرافي يشبه وظيفتي الأولى
ولا أعرف كيف أقول بشكل
صحيح وأحب أن أصنع مقاطع فيديو عتيقة  تحدث ، إنها
وسيلة تواصل اجتماعي لطيفة لإظهار ما
أراه في الحياة الواقعية ، وفي
يوم من الأيام قررت أن أجعل اتجاهًا مثل
الإيطالي وعلى وشك
جعل الأشياء الإيطالية منطقية مثل شيء من
هذا القبيل
وقررت أن أشاهد
الأشياء الموجودة في ملجئي من القنابل  يبدو
منطقيًا وأعتقد أنه بعد ذلك ، بدأت مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بي
في أن تصبح أكثر شيوعًا
وهذا أحد
الأسباب التي تجعلني أبدأ في جعل ذلك وأشعر
أن مهمتي هي أن أظهر للناس
كيف تبدو في الحياة الواقعية.
وانا هنا
انت